in January 2006 the new horizons space
probe was launched its mission to study
Pluto and its moons after a decade of
travel on 14th of July it will arrive
for a brief encounter a flyby that will
be over in a matter of hours the real
excitement will start on Sunday the 12th
of July as New Horizons approaches Pluto
the onboard camera will photograph both
Pluto and its biggest moon Charon
beaming the images back to earth on
Monday the 13th NASA will receive a
final set of pictures before the flyby
New Horizons is traveling so fast that
even colliding with the dust particles
around Pluto could prove fatal these
images make sure that we will have at
least some close-up images of Pluto
before the most difficult phase of the
mission begins at midnight New Horizons
will then turn its radio antenna away
from Earth and focus its attention on
Pluto and Charon cutting our contact for
nearly 24 hours from this point New
Horizons is on its own at 7:40 9 a.m. on
Tuesday New Horizons will pass just
12,000 kilometers from Pluto its closest
approach and its best chance to take
detailed photos and readings of Pluto's
surface but it has to work quickly as
the tiny probe will whiz by Pluto at
almost 50,000 kilometers an hour just 14
minutes after it passes Pluto this
spacecraft will arrive at Sharon Sharon
is half the size of Pluto and may be
hiding secrets of its own
at 851 a.m. the capsule will pass into
Pluto's shadow as sunlight shines
through Pluto's atmosphere
New Horizons will use its onboard
instruments to investigate the chemical
signature of the gases then an hour and
a half later
New Horizons will pass into Sharon's
shadow scientists aren't expecting
Charon to have an atmosphere but if it
does this will be our best chance to
observe it once the flyby is complete
after almost a day of radio silence
New Horizons can finally turn its
antenna if all goes well
New Horizons will start beaming its data
back to earth slowly its radio antenna
uses less power than a standard light
bulb to send information through five
billion kilometres of space we'll have
to wait in agonizing 16 months for the
transfer to complete
over a decade after its launch New
Horizons is ready to complete its
mission and reveal Pluto's long kept
secrets